бузковий Гай - Це є символ всієї країни
Для мене вони ну щось подібно до Героїв
Крут бо вони без зброї ну принаймні
проти танкової точно вийшли проти
російських Танків і БМП з коктейлями
Молотова це ж не жарт і це не образ
якогось письменника це правда то не мав
зброї прийшов з ножем хто не мав ножа
прийшло з коктейлем і для мене це от
чомусь яскравий символ Героїв Крут ми
шануємо наших Героїв Крут і ми не
вшановуємо бо чекаємо чогось ті Хто
заслуговує має зараз бути вшанований тут
для того щоби кожен хлопець який іде
зараз зі зброєю в руках проти ворога
знав що його не кинуть і його батьків і
його родичів і його родину І про них
будуть пам'ятати